professor piert dear peter
dear professor bruce afero ladies and
gentlemen
when we are talking about the pandemic
it is usually hard
to find good news but when we look at
science the picture is completely
different
if there has been one bright spot in
this crisis
it was the unprecedented level of
scientific collaboration
this international collaboration has
enabled fantastic
breakthroughs of course i'm first and
foremost thinking of the
development and authorization of
vaccines
in record time you know that what
normally takes five to ten years
scientists made possible in less than
one
year today
i want to discuss with you how we can
strengthen
this cooperation even further
because the next pandemic must not find
us
unprepared health is a global public
good
it must be accessible to all people in
all countries
and this is why the italian g20
presidency
and the european commission decided to
host a global health
summit on may 21st in rome
together we want to agree on a roam
declaration of principles such
principles can be a
powerful guide to prevent future crises
and to be more resilient in the face of
future global health threats
because even if this current crisis is
not over yet
we need to take a long-term view
already now and this is why i want this
declaration to be embedded
in sound scientific evidence and
real world experience and for this
we need experts like you who are dealing
with global health
challenges on a daily basis
and therefore i'm really grateful to all
of you
for making it possible to participate in
this panel
already for the second time i'm
particularly pleased
that we have experts from so many
different countries
with us because each country has had
its own experience during this crisis
and i'm sure that this panel will draw
from these experiences
there are many important questions to be
discussed
what scientific and public health action
is needed
to prepare for future health threats
how can we better involve research
groups
from low and middle income countries
how can we overcome the lack of
diagnostics
and the shortcomings in the management
of test data
and importantly how can we avoid that
science is politicized
often with poor outcomes as consequence
the world is waiting for answers
in the european union we have already
started to act
with our hera incubator we want to get
ahead of the curve in the next phase of
the virus
for example we're boosting our
production capacity in europe
production capacity for europe but
also for the rest of the world just
as we're doing right now with vaccines
that are being delivered to europe and
vaccines
exported around the world
we are accelerating the development of
vaccines
and we are stepping up research
and data exchange between science and
industry
because in times of crisis time
is of the essence
and last but not least our ambition
must be to achieve the same level of
preparedness
at a global level especially in the low
and middle income countries
and for the most vulnerable and this
is why we need your input
your ideas your expertise
and your passion i'm very much looking
forward to our discussions
and i thank you for giving us your
precious time
and expertise thanks a lot